la russie surveille de près la présence
de navires américains dans les eaux de
la mer noire elle suspecte des
manoeuvres militaires en collaboration
avec le cren on retrouve tout de suite
notre correspondante à moscou vera
goffman
grosjean verra comment réagissent les
autorités russes face à ces exercices
militaires américains
bonjour sotchi la russie suit de près
les manoeuvres des navires de guerre
américains envers noir affirmé le porte
parole du ministère russe de la défense
igor konachenkov la préoccupation de la
russie porte notamment sur la présence
du destroyer reporter du temps car jean
lannes talent ainsi que le navire
amphibie oss mont whitney la russie
considère ces exercices militaires
imprévus comme un facteur déstabilisant
pour la région je vous propose d'écouter
nous notons qu'il s'agit d'actions
imprévues des forces américaines qui
créé un groupement multinationale de
forces armées à proximité immédiate de
la frontière russe de telles actions
sont un facteur de déstabilisation dans
la région de la mer noire l'un de leurs
objectifs étant l'exploitation du
territoire de l'ukraine sur le plan
militaire compte tenu du fait qu'en plus
de la marine américaine il est prévu
d'impliquer l'aviation tactique deux
patrouilles et stratégiques ainsi que
des contingents des forces armées
bulgare géorgienne roumaine turc et
ukrainienne nous constatons que l'étude
d'un théâtre d'opérations militaires
potentielles est en cours dans le cas où
kiev préparait un recours à la force
dans le sud est
le chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov avait réagi aux manoeuvres
américains dans la mer noire qui avait
commencé lors du sommet du g20 à rome en
disant que la russie était prête à
affronter n'importe quelle menace
écoutez
nous sommes prêts à faire face à toute
menace il n'existe pour nous aucun
problème afin d'assurer de manière
fiable la sécurité du territoire russe
et en mer noire no mercy corps mais nous
sommes toujours favorables à la
promotion de projets de coopération et
non de projet basée sur la confrontation
quant à la flotte américaine et la
fiente que les navires de guerre présent
dans la mer noire et avaient été
déployés pour renforcer la collaboration
entre les forces des etats-unis et de
l'otan en mer
merci beaucoup verhaeghe of mana en
direct de moscou